[Music]
in robot cruelty is submitted by Disney
takeover YouTube removed several videos
of robots fighting for breaking it's
animal cruelty policies good why was it
a bot YouTube remove videos of robots
fighting and labeled it animal cruelty
all that it's not funny serious that
makes me sad
where they robot dogs um so the thing is
a lot of them push there are robot
robots
Niki mix it mix it did I do have animal
name sometimes all the identifiers box I
mean in the title so they'll have animal
related names I don't know what exactly
but Apple versus wolfy probably tiger
vs. and these are the same people de
monetizing art videos who are the damn
gate keepers videos get D monetize we
have opinions girl and we say not even
doing anything wrong we just have
opinions that they don't like yeah
because you know how they changed things
where now people can automatically flag
videos for whatever reason that's what
yeah like they could say that they got
emotionally disturbed oh yeah like puts
the power in the yeah so bad because if
you look like a group of haters it's
like every video they don't even care
about yeah they don't they don't think
about that yeah do you struggle with at
all um oh man there was a period like ad
pocalypse
that was rough I think it's a bit better
now we've kind of learned how to like
play around it bugs we got team I have
like a main YouTube editor and then we
have like a team editor so I have him
like manage the team and I manage him
the way you're supposed to do it yeah
cuz are you audience music from the
games no from the games yeah but any
other music gone oh I had this one video
for a million views and there was like
10 seconds with sunflower so yeah and
I'm like I'm telling a story I'm like
guys I went to the grocery store today I
like
it's not available I like tryst in the
backup it's like a four million views
they just let us to monetize that part
can go on the other parts if it was if
they took a chunk of money depending on
the percentage that that showed up yeah
it doesn't make sense how they can get
all of it royalty free music from like
an MCN like six years ago and that was
the royalty free music and then now
they're claiming all these copyrights on
old ass videos and like there's nothing
you could do about it that happen to us
yeah so the robot can yeah I will show
you guys a clip I don't know if I can
handle this so [ __ ] cruel just turn
away I'll tell you I'll tell you
warning did they at least eat them
afterwards done this sure makes me sad
you know that this is triggering me this
is triggering me sorry look away if
you're gonna get triggered I'm gonna be
traumatized what's the difference
between this and monster trucks that -
no this is like cockfighting in a modern
day it is cockfighting no stop it tip
stop it it's no and it's child abuse
look at all the children witnessing this
violence no they found a way to not hurt
anybody and the chainsaw thing isn't
even doing anything I know this is your
naxi oh yeah what's turning on I think
the real crime here is how lame those
robots are we're gonna be strangling
each other they're just like RC cars
what if I can robot with this [ __ ] axe
that's like
see how crazy robots are nowadays oh
those robot dogs ah like acumen robot
dogs like from that one black mirror and
I said I but they made like something
like legit like exactly about the robot
B's from Black Mirror that go up in
there they get hacked and they kill
people through the nose that's crazy I
mean okay maybe demonetised up but she
was literally every black mirror episode
period but yeah so then here they were
saying that a lot of videos were getting
taken down and they were they were
citing animal cruelty so like here's one
as a troll algorithms [ __ ] it they're
not even [ __ ] animals
so the tweet says today it's a sad day
robot builders across the world cried
out in agony as YouTube's algorithm
falsely identified personal videos of
robot sport as animal cruelty and cop
fighting today I lost 9 videos but
others lost hundreds more if you were
affected do your part and let YouTube
knows save our sports and then it's like
the email example saying that it
contained animal suffering
so it says content that displays the
deliberate infliction of animal
suffering or the forcing of animal maybe
because it's an AI YouTube is just run
by AI it's run by an outward ease like
my kind is creepy it's [ __ ] creepy or
maybe those cars are running over a [ __ ]
ton of roaches we don't see Sara Lee oh
[ __ ] that is animal cruelty like 3,000
roaches dying
algorithm caught all the little apps and
bugs they're like that's animal routine
the dirt like a roach guts all over the
place so then YouTube did bring some
videos back up saying like oh you know
sorry but all the money's gone I know
then there they respond to that by
saying you know you can always a
rebuttal or appeal you could always
appeal any videos I have [ __ ] you don't
do pilot I'm kidding no you too
but then people were saying that now
that they've changed it to YouTube
studio I think it's called like the way
you upload videos and stuff now they've
made it like you have to go through a
lot of different pages and like search
for the appeal button Oh
so it's harder it's a lot more
complicated so it's like dude what the
hell it's not cool man what's going on
with you two that's tragic I think they
lost control of their algorithm honestly
I think you think the AI Wow yeah and
that's why when you tried to complain
about something they just have a script
that they read and they just pass it to
it's like a circle of people they just
keep passing it to and they all read
from the same script and you never get
an answer from a human being because
they don't have and they're fighting
back because they're like you guys are
[ __ ] up our animals this is cruelty
to our animals these are our robots
yeah and then they're gonna take over
our minds yeah now and that's why
everyone's so depressed is because the
algorithms making them
I thought the algorithm could make its
own videos to it like it just splices
together what's trending and then it
makes its own video probably what's next
yeah no I remember reading an article we
might have even talked about it here but
there is a pretty soon they're gonna
start having a news channel when it's
it's just all ran by AI it's actually a
thing like that in gaming already that's
like a website and all the articles are
just automated oh yeah and if I would
make money like it's just about making
the articles oh they work them too hard
so I don't even need like journalists or
writers in the floor I also read one
that they're they created an AI that can
write complete novels yeah what the [ __ ]
someone knows it knows how to make
perfect movies trailers for move oh that
one too yeah that one just you the ones
that like can or it can like operate on
a grape yeah surgery on a grape if we
look at the bright side we don't ever
have to work again hey I would do
everything yeah but on the bright on the
dark have money for working well what do
they need us for tired for the job like
my computer so good and then I could you
have a resume for your computer like why
I should get that job know how cute your
will this soda is compared to what I'm
at
oh we get to hang out because we don't
need money no there are slaves
no what no there weren't slaves we may
claim farm is that how you feel about
your toaster my sister's my I'm Jewish I
say [ __ ] total buzz and you like you
do the [ __ ] heating once the toaster
can make its own bread and toast it when
it wants it doesn't need me anymore so
you'd be like [ __ ] you I'm still eating
the bread yeah they're not gonna we're
gonna have a I do all the farming for us
yeah they're just gonna be happy I'm
gonna have a computer that prints money
I'm just being vulnerable you guys oh I
understand I feel like we're all just
slaves to whoever knows how to make
these hey guys
well right now we're slaves to people so
you know I don't know like money we're
slaves to the [ __ ] wagon here yeah
yeah I'm a slave to consumerism and like
I just want to but she was all day and I
saw her by I want to buy things for my
house I want buy things for my car I
want to buy things for my body I want to
buy I want to buy all kinds of things
all buy things for my husband and at me
I'm religious doesn't mean religious
people advise them yeah I'm just saying
that that consumers and powers don't
have anything on me because I believe in
religions then we're learning where'd
you get that piano from but you guys
look what your fault I do it to praise
my spirits don't even them I do it to
see the spirits everything's very this
is a blessed day with holy water okay
let's do it
you're a slave to video games ah
kind of yeah I think content creators
are slaves to the to their audiences oh
yeah yeah you gotta come that's monkey
I'm like I don't want to yeah I feel so
guilty when I don't upload to my I'm a
bad person
oh wow [ __ ] you can hug deep yeah okay
guys I'm fine cut deep for you I think
you're a bad person
thank you you're not a bad person okay
prior is love from do okay I think
you're I think you're a great person
[ __ ] what did I do
I feel like the hair style that you're
rocking right now goes with everything
it allowed to play outside now this ship
freaks me the [ __ ] out though really
like I can't start I can't like put my
mind in it because then I'm just like oh
[ __ ]
like I just see my doom approaching very
quickly so I try not to think about it
you guys ever heard Elon Musk talk about
this [ __ ] just hearing Elon Musk just
talk as he sounds he sounds worried
about this [ __ ] and he sounds like
someone that doesn't worry and this is
like his sole concern yeah and he sounds
like like not someone he's something a
robot there's this one podcast he did
with Joe Rogan you guys - Janet just
that one sound bit that's like I tried
to yeah but they did it was I told Obama
put a Tesla in space oh I mean part of
the problem bed with the technology
going forward he's trying to escape this
planet yeah he's like I already got my
teleport out bigger then he and like
Stephen Hawking and like all these guys
come up with like a avengers crew that's
against singularity yes yes yeah well
they're just negative thinkers because I
want to army of robots well the human
one that was saying that the a guy that
we are feeding is the Internet yes that
is AI is worth learning and we're
teaching it everything I hate when
YouTube says that like it's but
algorithms learning and then it's gonna
tell you what you want to see well
they're gonna know a lot about porn but
I think 70% the Internet is just porn so
that's gonna be a sexy AI so fuzzy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]